latéraux surprise viendra même se
réduire à une question sur stéphane
durand questions sur stéphane aussi avec
les accords 1 voilà tu pose pas de
questions sur les deux joues pas mon
bébé ne t'inquiète pas attention la
colle du chômage je vous le dis comme
ces doudous demandant de 2 pendant
pendant je vous lis pendant le facebook
live sur facebook l'être pendant la pub
vous vous étiez déguisé en bibi saillie
celle qui chantait doucement n'en peut
plus attention première question lors de
sa première rencontre avec le personnage
de kad merad que fait malik bentalha
dans le film est ce qu'il essaie de lui
vendre un mauvais doudou est ce qui lui
rend le bon doudou ou est ce qu'ils lui
présentent laetitia boudou on essaie de
lui vendre un mauvais de doux ouais on
bosse et payer c'était très bien pu si
la neige va du ciel on va regarder tout
de suite ni la bonne réponse et la toque
à toulouse où ma fille ça vous ferait
plaisir nous revoici quand on peut
rendre service
il s'est pas fait ça aussi si vous êtes
élu vous ne reconnaissez pas du tout ça
fait longtemps qu'on voulait pas vu mais
c'est le bo boudou c'est un miracle
regarder
ça passe en franchement enfin j'veux
dire ça passait le bon quoi c'est là en
plus on va faire de discrimination tous
les jours ce n'est ses goûts attendait
s'il vous plaît monsieur finition à
votre hiver a même pas la différence
je suppose que tu appelles en fonte mais
j'entends rapport mais s'il vous plaît
de minutes tu peux peut-être vous aider
à le retrouver mais avant ça trouve un
petit arrangement quoi tu me fait croire
que tu as retrouvé mon dos et en profite
pour faire les poches non c'est parce
que oui je vous explique qu'une chose
c'est qu'ici je connais tout le monde
j'ai accès à tous les services se classe
à la cotation qui a vu le film on va
parler d'un autre truc là on va parler
des lycées - dans un instant mais pour
l'instant dans le film pattaya ce qu'il
faut voir tout ce qui a fait ma vie
bentalha sauvage de manic temps d'être
célèbre en pratique au en participant
une télé ralité quel est le nom de cette
téléréalité jettera pas que tu l'avais
vu j'en étais c'était un babouin sinon
rien alors d'art contemporain ou s'ils
ont assez bien c'était quoi il des gros
dans ce face à face thaïlande
et ses rollers
[Applaudissements]
en france ici on va voir cet extrait ou
qui vient sur pattaya qui en dvd
actuellement nombreux sports franck
gastambide est on en droit social de
reparler d'anouar dans cette émission
vous verrez pourquoi allez c'est parti
et vous il a tout fait pour être connu
parce que quand tu es connu pas même si
très moche sarah super chaud comme de la
bête démarche
alors il a passé les castings de x pas
un jeu de télé réalité où c'est qu'il
faut des gros sur une île et leur
donnerait du temps à bouffer jour n'est
pas de ces gros tu dégages
on ne nous avait pas les codes touche à
des baisses on était loin de là c'est
pas la peine de crier et moi j'écris
pour ta mèche pour hilla j'écris pour
toi mais je pourris toiture quoi
[Applaudissements]
exactement
pour l'astag la décadence du secondaire
dans quelle série diffusée sur tf1 elie
semoun jouer le rôle d'un coursier au
patin à roulettes oui alors vous allez
finir mobile ou bono chamoiseau nos noms
et prénoms con c'était quoi n'importe
quoi ces livres dont l'indien sur
vivement lundi des maladies c'était en
4,88 à toi c'est bon c'est la raison cet
incident comme tf1 diffusée le dimanche
c'est un bétail et boulot y'a que les
trios j'adore parce que surgira dubaï et
elle nous fait des lancements genre à la
tf1 vous n'auriez pas la vidéo quand
même de son nom mais on est sur lequel
le gave à la vidéo mais
[Musique]
tha
c'est
[Musique]
je ne veux pas changer et non la whey du
trou je te jure exactement la même
mais je te jure est vachement kelly ah
non non pas du tout le même à la même
espèce de manchots n'ont franchement pas
trop changé toujours bien la mélasse
mois moi j'aime mais moi j'aime bien
tout le temps moi j'aime encore mieux
maintenant voilà je crois que les futurs
élèves alors regarde quoi c'est votre
délire allez moi je trouve que plus
vieillit mieux
il encaisse lui si la chose se passe un
truc là alors il est heureux là bas il
est content et son numéro de téléphone
touche tâche sera surtout cependant de
vous coûter 1
bagis d isabelle c'est gentil merci
c'est bien celle là j'aimerais le voir
ensemble deux années ensemble
alors toi c'est ton dos ou pas j'ai si
bien sûr que ce sont des livres bien sûr
mais bien à une autre lors de la
cérémonie des césar en 2009
à quel acteur américain eli semoun at il
rendu hommage à laure sinon ça va vous
traiter la mi 2009
alors 2009 2009 il n'a rien foutu non
mais là rien [ __ ] c'est vraiment dû
réviser les oscars nécessaire tout neuf
réviser les invités mais vise les
invités réunis des abats bravo les
autres alors est-ce si on a offert qui
donne la bonne réponse on va arrêter
dessus de cette émission je venais
malick où tu le sais quoi à bali mali
dustin hoffman
vous étiez vous en ai voulu à dire en
dehors de nos bases regarde pas du tout
une femme dans les canons de beauté ne
correspondent pas à la norme
merci merci d'avoir donné la parole aux
femmes d'âge il ne recourant pas en
paillettes de la chirurgie esthétique
comme c'est trop souvent le cas dans
d'autres professions
mais soyez vous même et si vous n'y
arrivez pas il a peut-être une autre
solution
être un homme c'est un goût de rage
parce que j'ai fait un an levée de
perruques comme thème c'est vrai mais ça
je suis fou de sart délire et j'ai
complètement fonds va revoir comme à
chaque fois que tu viens juste parce que
c'est il nous reste à quand il ya eu
jermaine jackson billets et d'adoration
obligé c'est un autre gros fou rire de
tout entière et je vous rappelle à
chaque fois pourquoi j'ai eu un sourire
section pas le talent émission et je
vois jermaine jackson frère il y au
musée grévin le gardien il est en statue
de cire je sais que le gars il bouge pas
mon frère il est comme as depuis le
début de l'émission et je vois je sais
qu'il ya l'autre avec ça qui va rentrer
et je voulais comment le gard marc elle
va réagir et claude qui va le sentais
pas et je croise le regard délai qui lui
aussi dit tu es sûre il m'a dit
d'arrêter sur d'une autre série
t'inquiète ça va passer crème
[Applaudissements]
huawei
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'amène
un sceau de la piscine it will it is
fixait le tact il selon la chaîne ap
[Applaudissements]
dernière question pour vous qu'est ce
qu'il vous faut malik bentalha déjà été
chroniqueur dans tpm p bref quant à ces
deux jours il pleuvait va pas durer
mille ans non et c'était sur france 4
je me rappelais plus du tout à fait vrai
on va se revoir un extrait 2011 bref
vous allez voir un extrait 2 bioware du
mali bnda suis très très content de
recevoir malik bentalha parce que si
voilà je vous le dis c'est le mec qui me
fait le plus marrer en ce moment mais
c'est vrai je rentre je me suis senti
j'ai pris la ligne
ça me prend tout le temps la ligne 9
vous voulez me croiser une amie vous
prendre la ligne
j'apprends tout en nation bonne nouvelle
comédie club ça prend parfois la ligne 9
que tout le monde me reconnaît dessus a
pas très longtemps il ya un mec il est
rentré sur la ligne 9 toujours que c'est
vrai là commence à faire bonjour à tous
messieurs dames comme vous le voyez je
suis malheureusement sans emploi malik